Hey youtubers it's Charlie and during my episode
9 review I asked you all to submit questions
so I picked 10 to answer and one bonus question.
I also said I'd dedicate some time to the
other plots that they didn't show. So a lot
of the questions I picked include that stuff.
Real quick, congrats to manuel sacha. You're
this weeks winner of the giveaway. You win
a $20 amazon gift card. I'll be messaging
you on your channel for details.
The next round of the giveaway will start
when I post my finale video. Since it's the
finale I'm going to be giving away two gift
cards. I'm still going to do a weekly giveaway
but I might move it to a different weekly
video like doctor who or something else.
So here's some cool facts from the episode
that some of you guys pointed out in the comments.
Feel free to shout if you were one of the
people that commented on these things. There
were a lot of you that saw stuff.
First off, Tormund Giantsbane is replacing
the Val character from the books as the person
they keep as a prisoner at the Night's Watch.
Pip and Grenn weren't killed in the book.
I saw a lot of you that were more sad to see
them go than you were to see Ygritte die,
which I thought was really funny.
and that battle between Jon Snow and the Thenn
at the end was an homage to Donal Noyal. He's
a night's watch character from the book that
they cut out of the show. He was the blacksmith.
Which is why Jon rolls over the forge and
kills the thenn with the Blacksmith's hammer.
In the books Donal was the one who went into
the tunnel to keep the giant from entering
castle black instead of that group of night's
watch brothers.
and Japanese Zombies suggested that the girl
maester aemon was talking about was one of
his sisters Rhae or Daella. Because that would
have been the Targaryen tradition. I don't
know if it's true, but it's the best suggestion
I saw in the comments.
So time to answer some questions. Careful
for spoilers from the episode if you haven't
seen it yet. Here we go. Question 1 - Kami
asks Do you think Brienne will fight The Hound?
Based on the way they edited the teaser for
episode 10 it does look like they want us
to think that. If you look at this first picture
it's Brienne unsheathing Oathkeeper, then
it cuts to Arya and the Hound approaching
someone that looks like they're wearing armor
like Brienne's.
This would be a big departure from the books,
but a way to do something similar. I don't
want to say what happened to any of those
characters in case book stuff turns into spoilers.
But where things are now with Arya and the
Hound and Brienne and Podrick are really different.
The show changed the way Ygritte died last
night but she did die during the attack in
the books. So it's like they change things
but still end things in similar ways.
Question 2 - Nicole asks What Happened to
Ghost?
He's just hanging out recovering from the
battle. He's not dead or anything. They don't
put the wolves in every scene because they
have to add CG to regular sized wolves and
it's expensive.
The dragons are really eating most of the
CG budget this season and they're a big part
of the finale. So expect to get a crazy dragon
scene next week. It looked like Ghost didn't
go with Jon to Mance's camp either, so we
probably won't see him next week. But he's
just fine.
No new direwolves have died since Nymeria
ran off and Lady and Grey Wind were killed.
Question 3 - Fatema asks Why did Jon go to
Mance Rayder's Camp without a weapon?
I saw a lot of you guys asking this question,
it's because Mance doesn't know what Jon has
done. He still thinks he's with the raiders.
It's a bit of a plot hole, because if the
raiders used a warg to learn their defences.
Why wouldn't Mance use a warg to do the same
thing, and see Jon Snow wearing the black.
The other reason he didn't take longclaw was
because he made a promise to never lose it
again. So by leaving it with Sam he was insuring
that it wouldn't be lost if he got killed.
Jon said he's going to try and kill him, but
I think they'll stick to the book plot. I
won't say what that is just because spoilers,
and if you have read the books please use
the spoiler tag when commenting about it.
Question 4 - Steve asks Do you think the title
of the finale being "The Children" foreshadows
The Children of The Forest?
Yes, I think we'll meet one via Bran's group.
It looks like they reach that weirwood he's
been seeing in his dreams.
I also think the title refers to Daenerys'
children the Dragons and the Stark Children
in general. There's one shot from the season
4 trailer before the season started that we
haven't seen in an episode yet beneath Daenerys'
Pyramid in Meereen.
I won't say more about that because it's kind
of spoilery if you haven't read the books.
And as for Stark children, think about Brienne's
mission and the fact she's probably going
to run into Arya and The Hound. She's thinking
in her head she's supposed to return Lady
Catelyn's children to safety.
But first and foremost the episode will probably
tease the Children of The Forest and they'll
make that a bigger part of the story in Season
5.
Question 5 - Jose asks, can Giants be turned
into White Walkers?
Their corpses can be turned into wights, but
the only way they'd be able to make a new
white walker giant is to turn it as a child.
There's a rumor inside the canon of the book
that Bran the builder used magic to enslave
giants to help him build the wall.
Question 6 - Daniel asks Would Sam become
the new Maester if Jon Snow became the new
Lord Commander?
It wouldn't have anything to do with Jon becoming
Lord Commander, but whoever was the current
Lord Commander would probably just appoint
a new Maester. That would only happen after
Maester Aemon died and we didn't see him die
during the battle.
Jon would definitely pick Sam. As for Janos
Slynt or Aliser Thorne, I don't know if they'd
appoint Sam, but probably. There aren't really
any other brothers available for the job with
the necessary skills.
But if Sam really wanted to be a Maester he'd
have to go study at the Citadel and earn his
Maester's chain. Otherwise he couldn't call
himself a maester.
Question 7 - Sarah asks which characters do
you think got the best treatment from the
writers this season?
You're asking about which characters has the
show been pushing as the most important. Peter
Dinklage definitely. I saw a chart after like
season 2 that compared the screen time everyone
got and there were definitely a small group
of people that got way more compared to season
1. Peter Dinklage has always gotten the most
even if you think Daenerys is the most important
character.
But generally the characters this year that
have gotten the biggest push have been tyrion,
jaime and cersei, daenerys, and Jon Snow.
After that the rest of the lannisters and
the starks get way less screen time and after
that the rest of the secondary characters
get almost nothing.
In terms of fan favorites, I think Tyrion
will walk away the big winner this year.
Question 8 - Iona asks Do you think they'll
still finish the season on something to do
with ice?
Yes, I think it will end on something with
Bran. They typically alternate between Daenerys
scenes and scenes in the North.
Question 9 - Lorie asks, was the wall built
to keep out white walkers or wildlings? Didn't
giants help build it?
The wall was built to seal off the lands of
always winter from the rest of Westeros. That's
where the white walkers retreated to at the
end of the long winter. Yes giants helped
and the free folk. Everyone that lived in
the north helped build the wall.
The wall is about a thousand years old. So
it existed before the andals invaded and formed
the seven kingdoms. That's when relations
with the first men who survived the invasion
deteriorated. Anyone not wishing to bow to
a king just moved North of the wall. They
became what you would call the wildlings.
But they're really called free folk.
It's been so long since the last battle with
the white walkers that everyone has forgotten
the wall isn't to keep the free folk out,
it's to keep the white walkers in.
I did a big video on the long night and the
building of the wall that goes into much greater
detail. I'll have a link to that in the description.
Question 10 - Alex asks which new characters
do you think will show up in season 5?
Mostly Martells and Dorne characters. I also
think we'll see some new characters in Braavos
and Meereen. I don't want to go too crazy
with spoilers so you can watch my season 5
video I did a couple weeks ago to learn more
if you want. There's another link in the description
for that.
Bonus Question - Mini Frost Giant asks If
you were a character on the show which god
would you worship?
If I got to choose what kind of a character
I would be I'd probably pick a Tyrell or Lannister
since the quality of life would be a thousand
times better. Just because I'd be rich. If
I could choose who to worship without my house
making fun of me too much I'd probably worship
the old gods.
But because the old gods and their disciples
the children of the forest were so linked
to defeating the white walkers during the
long night. I'd probably put my faith in them.
If they beat the white walkers once, they
can do it again.
I think you'd have an easier time convincing
the children to help you if you practiced
the same customs and religion.
So I'm just trying to increase my odds of
survival.
My second choice would be r'hollor. Because
at least he'd be able to bring me back if
I died.
So thanks so much for submitting questions,
these are always a ton of fun to do. Like
I said, my next bonus video will probably
be ranking all of the previous finales. Be
sure to subscribe to get it if you're just
finding me for the first time. There will
be at least two bonus videos before the finale.
Next week I'll probably do like 3 videos and
then it will be like one every sunday.
Right now click here for my episode 9 video
and click here to learn more about some of
the big prophecies on the show.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!